what I will do first before we sort of
get into the
to give you just a quick video for all
of you who don't know Poshmark or sort
of may have a certain impression of
Poshmark just give you like a one or two
minute video on what is Poshmark and
then we'll start sort of with it
closet and make cash while you do it
[Music]
Poshmark is the number one way to buy
and sell fashion listen anything from
shoes that don't quite fit to address
you've been photographed in one too many
times in just 60 seconds
[Music]
ready to find all the style you love on
Poshmark discovering the perfect look is
simple and fun
[Music]
[Applause]
love your purchase leave the seller a
love note to let them know join millions
of people across the country who are
buying selling and sharing fashion day
lives
[Music]
thank you so what I'm going to talk to
you a little bit about is sort of
something that isn't talked about as
much which is love and how it impacts
the growth of your business
I understand a lot of you are
engineering students and I'm at one day
I was sort of one myself which was
studying computer science but today sort
of what we are doing is really helping
in a broad sense people sell shoes and
clothes across the country and so I'm
going to share a little bit about my
journey from being a database nerd or
computer science graduate to sort of for
the last 1012 years building shopping
communities particularly centered around
fashion and today Bosch mark is actually
going beyond fashion into other areas as
well so before we get started let me
share a little bit about myself so I
grew up in India I was there for the
first 19 years of my life I came here in
87 when I was 19 years old I grew up
primarily in multiple different cities
and I think part of what shaped me was
the fact that as I had to move from city
to city I had to adapt and quickly sort
of respond to changing climates ever
imagine as a kid moving from school to
school constantly it was kind of a
trauma a byproduct of that was for some
reason I got to skip a couple of grades
so I finished high school when I was 15
which was both good and bad in some ways
it sort of sounds interesting but you're
trying to then leave home and go to a
different city and get into a college
and try to study anyhow how many of your
freshmen here any freshman so if you can
imagine being a freshman at fifteen and
having come to a school and and living
away from your town it was kind of a
crazy time and and there was a lot of
learnings there but but that was sort of
the foundation that was created which
was growing up in these in these small
towns and part of what that trained me
for was flexibility which is being able
to adapt to different circumstances
which is being a little bit of my
journey throughout my career as Robbie
mentioned I went to a school
Kalai I can pour which was in India and
and that was kind of an interesting
process too because I actually didn't
know what school I was going going to
because I was only 13 when I was
thinking about colleges and then sort of
suddenly realized that I wanted to go to
this very specific school called IIT
Kanpur which had this computer science
program and they only took 15 students
every year in this program and I told my
daddy that I'm gonna go to this program
I'm gonna sit out a year and he said are
you crazy
you got applied to more schools than
this one school and I said no it's
that's the only school I want to go to
so he forced me to apply to a couple of
their schools but I was sort of very
hyper focused on getting into this this
program and the way that that admissions
process works is you get ranked and and
based on your ranking you get to select
which school you get to so there's like
six or seven IITs that's more now so I
got I think I my rank was like 41 or 43
which typically would not get you into
that school which typically would get
you two into a different school but
somehow that year one two three four
five ranks chose to go to a different
IIT so I was a fifteen student admitted
so I think some of my life has been
shaped by good luck as well where
serendipity and good luck and in focused
sort of get you into these things anyway
was a great experience learned a lot and
from there I came to Texas and went to
UT Austin a sort of doing I enrolled for
a ph.d program but after while decided
that that was sort of not a journey that
I wanted to pursue so to come Astor's
dropped out and moved to the valley and
enjoined Intel and my first job was
actually building database software for
storing semiconductor data and there
used to be a job like that in 89
because there was no professional
databases at that time things like
Oracle and MongoDB and SQL did not
actually exist so we were still hand
cobbling databases in those days after a
year I realized that that was not
something I wanted to do so I looked
around and found that I want to really
work for a database company and moved
across the bay to Berkeley to work for a
company at that time called Sybase and
when I was at Intel Intel at I I think
eight to ten thousand employees so my
next job was with a company which are
only 80
he's at that time accidentally without
realizing I joined a start-up and that
was the good part
the bad part for those of you familiar
that startups was we were in 1990 we
were going through a Matt bad recession
in Silicon Valley and Sybase was not
able to raise a round of funding so they
had bridge capital when I joined and
they just laid off ten percent of their
workforce and fortunately for me I was
not savvy to any of these topics I was
very excited about living in Berkeley
and working for a database technology
that was really really sophisticated and
sort of gave me the learning that I
wanted to do and so what happened was
within a year the recession turned
around the company grew by the time I
left it five years later we were six
thousand people we had filed we become
public we're one of the top database
companies and to me the moral of that
story was really great again around
pursuing what you love and focus on when
you sort of do things in a very
calculated way in a top-down way it may
work out it may not work out in this
case I was just pursuing something that
I wanted to do more from the perspective
of what I loved and that is sort of how
my entire career has shaped out
including starting the two companies
it hasn't mean oh I want to start a
company in collaborative consumption or
or something is just sort of organically
evolved in the process and so I was
there at Cypress for a long time and
then I realized that the company had
become too big for me so then I joined
another company called versus ARRA which
had a couple of XIV's people and it had
only eight employees at that time now we
were in a completely different world in
that company we were building
applications for Microsoft platforms and
this was 95 and the world was shifting
towards the first wave of internet and
at that point in time what ended up
happening was that as the world was
shifting towards Internet we had to
pivot and actually professor bias if
he's in the room I was taking his class
right before that time and learning
about concepts called crossing the chasm
focusing etc and as this neophyte MBA at
this company I was trying to persuade
the CEO to apply those concept and was
failing but ultimately
those things helped me in a way because
we had to put all of our energies in
moving away from the Microsoft Windows
platform and moving to Internet back in
98 99 so so that that was sort of a time
of I would call extreme learning where
we were in a company that was going
through a major what we would call pivot
today where we had to actually go
through fighting off half the company to
go through that pivot but then we grew
from there and actually went public in
2000 and the company went from 8 to over
600 700 people and that was all of my
first state of success where I really
was there from the beginning
and grew the company but as I was
exiting the company we hit the second
recession in Silicon Valley which was
around Oh 102 that I experienced where
things were really bad this probably the
worst I've seen in the 30 years in
Silicon Valley and that allowed and
forced us to all reinvent ourselves so I
had to focus on reinventing myself from
being an engineer and I had I actually
took on the role of an investment banker
at that point in time and what I was
doing was really merge introducing
companies together and through that
process I was able to connect to
companies that one company ended up
acquiring another company and in that
process it became a new company and
invited me to join when I joined that
company I realized that this area that
specifically that working was not my
passion so I took all of that and my
wife is here and we took all of that and
applied that passion into remodeling our
home in that remodeling I discovered a
lot of problems that they were around
collaboration around shopping this was
back in 2003 2004 and from there emerged
my first company but as the idea was
forming I kept telling myself you know
I'm not the right guy to do this because
I know everything about enterprise
software building systems databases I
know nothing about consumer behavior I
know absolutely nothing about
advertising I know nothing about
collaborative models or web or internet
from an outside-in perspective so I kept
rejecting the idea but progressively
that idea became all-consuming and it
everything felt like a nail so it felt
like I could solve world hunger with
this little thing around social
collaboration to
that I was building which was called
caboodle at that point in time and part
of what I did was that this is sort of
high approach problems is creating the
necessary preconditions for success and
I would sort of again give you a piece
of thought is that wherever you're going
be amongst all of the journey you're
taking in terms of the schooling you're
getting etc if a direction you want to
get to trying to create the right
preconditions for success is very
important so for me that preconditions
came by actually becoming a volunteer in
several different local organisations
and taking and focusing my energy in
connecting with people who really know
what internet was so I connected in a
alums you know from IIT from Berkeley
etc and brought them into sort of
connection met with a couple of my
professors who are teaching you at
Stanford a couple of the guys who were
involved in Google in the early days but
also created a group of Internet
luminaries who were just starting out at
that time so through that I met with
Reid Hoffman Joe Kraus bunch of people
who I would not have met through in my
normal sort of process brought them all
together created a think tank which was
good for them but I was also learning
through that process and meeting folks
and so that was sort of some of the
preconditions I created before we
caboodle was getting born as Kaboodle's
started we really started in a garage
physically in a garage and very soon we
realized that the real true product
market fit for that product was around
women's shopping in women's community
and so by honing it on that sort of very
specific thing it was easy to find that
market fit however when I went to my
board my advisors ever even asked me a
simple question which was how can
shopping be social now you have to
remember this was 2005 and I'm a 51
tomorrow 51 year old man and at that
time I was sitting in a room of 40 year
old men and for them shopping being
social was very counterintuitive and so
we had to take a risk to really move
this thing in the world of social
shopping as we were going from a general
purpose collaboration tool fortunately
we did and the market adoption and and
we made everything sort of public and
super social this was circa Oh 5 or 6
even the
social shopping when we launched the
product you know six was
counterintuitive he had to explain what
is social shopping and remember going to
TechCrunch at Michael Arrington's office
and trying to explain to him and what is
social even mean in contact of shopping
social was somewhat of a paradigm the
social shopping was kind of an oxymoron
in those days and in that's how sort of
the kaboodle journey began and the
company sort of grew very fast in the
first couple of years but it was still
early days the monetization wasn't there
and in oh seven we were looking at two
options we had a term sheet from
Softbank and we had a acquisition offer
from Hearst fortunately for us we
actually ended up selling to Hearst at
that point in time and became part of
Hearst magazines art interactive I say
fortunately because after that oh eight
and oh nine happened and Oh 18 no nine
was another sort of recession
fortunately at this time I was sitting
in a very different situation where we
were actually scaling and growing very
fast at that period of time and this
journey of five or six years with
caboodle became my how many of you have
read Malcolm Gladwell's 10,000 hours
sort of metaphor Samantha Medford has
this book where he talks a little bit
about the fact that to really specialize
of growth skills in some areas you have
to spend at least 10,000 hours
practicing it right and so through this
five years this 10,000 hours that I
spent in this journey transformed me
from being just a database peak to now
knowing about community fashion working
with sort of a community which was
predominantly women and then marrying
technology and sort of these things
together so as I came out of this
company and finished my contract with
Hearst I wanted to do something which
mirrored these two things in the big
insight I had was that when we think of
really creating a shopping platform
which is focused around discovery
paradigms fashion style etc the scale
that we'd been able to achieve in
2009-2010 was very small and lot of it
was gated by the fact that people were
really trying to do everything in a very
structured algorithmic way and a lot of
fashion and style is a serendipity
discovery so the first thesis we had
going into this sort of whole problem
was that we
wanted to build something that was
really powered by people and the second
thing which was there which was
happening in oh nine or ten was iPhone
was just starting to come off age and
and I say iPhone because that was the
only mobile product worth using at that
time and so mobile was just starting to
come off age and that really led to sort
of the the creation of Poshmark
and what sort of clicked in my mind was
I was on a vacation and one of my
friends said did I phone for which was
about this big
where was the first phone which had very
high resolution camera and very high
resolution screen and he was able to
take a photo immediately upload it to
Facebook where I was with my SLR trying
to take a photo get the chip out shove
it into the laptop and trying to get it
in I said this is revolutionary right
now
and right on that time I discovered a
little app called Instagram which had
this notion of something called filters
but I said between these two things
we've suddenly empowered the consumer to
really create a dynamic fashion magazine
and in o.9 when we had the early idea of
Poshmark we were thinking it'll be a set
of fashion magazines that would connect
people to buy and sell so in 10 with
this platform it became clear that this
may be the right way to think about it
the challenge was the world was not
ready for it none of the investors at
that time really believed that mobile
will be the place where people would
shop so everyone was trying to convince
me why don't you just use it as selling
tool but really create a website around
shopping and for me that felt very
antithetical to sort of the whole
circular paradigm so the one big bet we
made which was sort of the insight was
that everything will be done on this
phone so we really focused on just one
thing which was to build an end-to-end
app around this area prior to sort of
even starting Poshmark
one of the preconditions for starting
Poshmark was when we started kaboodle it
was three guys all of us came from
technology background because again my
network were sort of confined to Silicon
Valley
so for Poshmark or sort of for the next
journey I said you know I have an
amazing network of people from
technology
you understand product and all of that
but I wanted to systematically bring in
a partner a co-founder who came deep
from fashion world and so I actually
spent the first half of 2010 even before
this epiphany around the the phone
happened really trying to figure out who
that right founder would be and met
actually several people who grew up in
the fashion business in New York and LA
who were here and finally met my
co-founder Tracy through Mayfield who
was one of the people who introduced me
and connect to her and we really ended
up sort of really sort of feeling
compatible in terms of how our values
whatever our shared vision was about the
future and then two of the other
co-founders got them in shaitaan' in
Poshmark
were actually with meme kabuto days both
were CTO and VP of engineering which is
the role that they play here and that
how sort of the initial team for
Poshmark came together but there was a
fifth missing piece because Poshmark is
very much powered around community and
so to get that community element I
actually went back to Kabul and
reconnected with the person who worked
in a very different role with me in in
caboodle and recruited her and she
didn't even know that she was actually
really good at it but I saw the
potential in her to bring her on as our
head of community and the five of us
were able to start Poshmark again back
to the garage days initial funding came
from Mayfield and Beth sort of the farm
on creating an end-to-end platform on
that little device called iPhone 4 at
that time now it seems like amazing you
know sort of serendipitous you know
mobile should have meant everything in
2010 to 11 if it's a huge risk in fact I
remember going to at least a dozen
different investors up and down Sand
Hill and everyone saying you know yeah
we like it but the conversion rates are
much higher on the web so you've
definitely launched a website we
actually didn't launch a website till
two years later and actually only
beginning of last year did I website
actually match up to industry standards
and web is actually a growth engine for
us in the last 18 months almost reverse
because the first five years were all
mobile for us the the beauty of that was
that we built everything so everything
happened on the phone which today people
are trying to get to
and we sort of started there and that
ended up being a huge competitive
advantage over the long term what I did
not know which happened in the kaboodle
days but also happen in the Poshmark
days was as we were starting the company
they were at least 70 to 80 other guys
who were trying to do the same thing
seven years later what's interesting
about our space is not the fact that
Poshmark is growing and scaling and
winning but that there is actually
probably eight or ten other companies
who are doing pretty well in this space
and the whole space is actually very
well formed at this point driving a lot
of growth in how fashion is being bought
and sold not just in the United States
but across the world and that is
something which I don't think I could
have predicted even at that journey is
how the entire sort of behavior of the
consumer will massively shift however
what we did from day one was put in a
couple of whole principles in place that
have guided the growth of the platform
and the first for fair for our business
was really focusing on love by that what
I mean is focusing on engagement and so
if you're building anything in the
consumer space I would say the number
one thing to focus on is engagement even
though everyone will tell you to focus
on growth growth comes but engagement is
something that is not easy to sort of
get or invent so for us the very first
ones into the product got the consumers
very deeply engaged and that was an
early sign of success where people were
and are spending somewhere between 20 to
25 minutes a day on the app and they
opened the app seven to nine times a day
and most people will activate as both
buyer and seller which makes the process
of building a marketplace much easier
because you don't have to focus on
supply or demand simultaneously so where
we are today is we have little over 40
million community members growing at the
rate of 40 50 percent a year in term
just the sheer community they continue
to remain engaged so every single user
who's joined the platform continues to
sort of scale up in its engagement and
strength levels we have roughly about a
hundred million dollars worth of
inventory that's uploaded on a weekly
basis what's really interesting is one
of the architectures we created was
mutual sharing of love so the platform
is built around the fact that each user
has to build a set of followers which is
not in counterintuitive all of you you
know because you're familiar with social
platforms you have to build this set of
followers
what's counterintuitive is that all your
items are primarily seen by just your
followers so which means in order to
grow your business you have to not just
build a network of followers you have to
engage with other people and what the
follower sees is all the items that are
being shared by the people that he or
she is following so you have to actually
share not just your own items but items
that other people list in order to build
your network so in that sense it behaves
like a social network so probably the
only marketplace where every seller
spends roughly half their time promoting
other sellers items now if you think
about it for a second how
counterintuitive is that how many people
know a marketplace where every seller
spends half their time promoting other
sellers but they don't do it because
they are just sort of in the world of
being good to other people they do it
because they also want to grow
however this sort of this particular
metaphor and by the way this metaphor
was an accident in the sense that the
curation was very deliberate to get
people to curate each other's items but
this interaction and engagement that
observation only happened later on as to
how it was facilitating as an extreme
expediter of community development
because you had to engage with other
people and what that does is it allows
us to continue to sort of build the
system without having to do all kinds of
retention and sort of proactively going
out and other pieces now when you think
about people sharing each other's items
there is a wisdom into it because as you
share other people's items you actually
become more and more savvy as a stylist
so we call our seller seller stylist
also it prevents us from introducing
things like advertising because we can
the the main focus is around sharing so
which keeps the core of the community
very pure
and so one of our first core values that
we've created in the platform is all
around putting the consumer first right
so when you think about the seller and
the buyer
because they are the same and because
they have to focus on other people and
those people have to focus on other
people the core of the community is
centered around people so our entire
shopping platform is not built on
products but are focusing on people and
I remember in 2010 standing in a cafe on
University Avenue and three or four of
us were sitting there and we just had
this epiphany that posh Punk is all
about people and that is still true and
we all give us a each other a big hug
because the entire product design
centered around that sort of single
concept of people what was beautiful is
that it also allows us to design a
company architecture so for example at
Poshmark today everyone who joined in
the first two and a half years of the
company every single employee is still
here with the company and they are still
scaling and growing with the company
many of them are senior executives many
of them are leaders in the in the group
but part of it is not just me putting
people first but everyone sort of
putting people first and that has
created a culture which you know
obviously takes a lot of effort and we
are going through as we are scaling at
different places to continue challenge
it but it creates an amazing culture
which particularly when you live in
Silicon Valley to have that longevity
across all all types of folks is very
hard to do you can only do it if you can
walk the walk and talk the talk and sort
of blend the two things so it allows us
to dovetail community and company
paradigms into into a single sort of
approach the second thing is we created
a partnership with our community where
we do not make any money off our
community we only make money when our
community makes money now think about
that for a second if you are in the
business of advertising you're actually
asking people to pay something whether
they make money or not right if you have
a service fee you're actually asking
people to pay a service fee whether they
make money or not right
imagine if Stanford changes entire
tuition system to say we'll only be
taking 5% of your future earnings and
nothing today by they would actually be
in a different position it'd be a very
radically different approach provided
you signed up for it right so we did
that from day one we said hey seller
anybody who sells on the platform will
have a 80/20 partnership with you
you keep 80% of revenue we keep 20% and
that's it there's gonna be no other fees
ever beyond that you'll never pay any
payment processing fee any shipping fee
any overweight be any charge back fraud
anything else no listing fees nothing so
we did that in 2011 in 2018 we have the
exact same fee structure if you think of
seven years in any marketplace any
single marketplace you can pick up if
you look at the number of times they've
changed the fees it would be at least
three to six whether you think of Amazon
eBay Etsy uber any of the sort of
marketplaces and part of the thing was
it was a it felt a little heavy early on
that people said or 20% it's a lot but
the reason we did that is we could
provide every single service and never
have to go back and touch that fee
structure right so we could lead and
focus on love and money comes and money
is sort of always a second order process
so we can focus on really delivering the
highest value and that guides us from
day one is we are in the service of our
seller stylist of our community and we
don't have to worry about anything else
everything else just gets taken care off
in the process so we always go with our
community we cannot grow outside them
because we don't make any money if they
don't make any money we just recently
announced we've distributed over a
billion dollars to our seller style is
distributed not just our revenue so it's
excludes our fees and everything else
and that is a great milestone because in
their success lies our success and it
never sort of disconnects ever at all
the the third thing which is around this
sort of love is very very critical
because if you have that as a core thing
then you can allow and scale the
platform without having to corrupt it
right and over time one of the
challenges that happens is when those
things become when love and money gets
disconnected and you start to become a
public company
whatever all these pressures start to
take you down into dark alleys right and
it's taken a lot of work upfront the
first three four years were super hard
but as you're scaling but inciting these
to pieces you can create something
really early so my sort of core take
away from this is as you go through your
journeys in life you know obviously are
very young and as you sort of evolve as
your own value systems get clearer think
of how you can create products and
services that can be meaningful have
economically sound foundation so we
didn't give away the product for free
we charge 20% partnership but over the
long term it becomes very symbiotic and
synergistic with what you want to do
right and that you're clarifying around
what your value systems are what you're
trying to do is very very powerful but
then being able to build products and
services that you can symbolize is even
more critical and particularly with the
amazing opportunity that all of you have
and the amazing opportunities that this
valley gives you in terms of growth I
think the responsibility that we have to
society is at an all-time high right and
so we have to be able to level up to
that responsibility and combine it and
integrate with all the amazing
opportunity and successes that all of
you are going to achieve and so one of
the beautiful parts of working at
Poshmark is that every day we get to see
the success of over 10 million people
who are actively selling and buying on
the platform and continue scale and we
have women who have gone from sort of
starting from their closets now running
million dollar businesses managing three
or four Fashioneds entirely on and
Poshmark we've heard stories of people
escaping abusive relationships using
Poshmark we've heard people who have
started again and built you know a multi
sort of city group and then of course
connection so that is fantastic and the
fact that we don't have to go and give
them another tax bill at the end of the
day is very very nice because they can
continue scale their business around
Poshmark and so that focus has been the
key the final thing i'm going to leave
with you which is a super important
thing is each of you is weird who
doesn't feel that they're or who feel
that they're weird
right starting from Intel and doing
helping women sell she was definitely
weird right but there's many other weird
noises I can talk about I'll tell you
one thing else is that the very first he
arrived in this country I was actually
nine months later performing on the
steps of the Texas State Capitol in
Mexican folk dance being part of the
Mexican folk dancing group so totally
embrace your weirdness and in your
weirdness you're also embracing everyone
else's weirdness and that's the power
the power is not about you it's really
about accepting everyone else for who
they are and in that process you can
create something much more robust so
when you think of our community and
think of the products they sell and
there's many platforms out there one of
the biggest things for us is that
fashion is universal so there's no
restriction to what you can sell on
bachmeier you can sell your $5 shirts
and you can sell your $5,000 handbag you
can sell something new you can sell
something old you can sell high and low
end and really by embracing everyone
what it does is creates much more robust
of a system and you'd be surprised even
if you look around and you look at your
closet or around what you find is that
people have all kinds of mixtures and
they actually go through all kinds of
journeys and by bringing it all together
and figuring out a way to have them all
work together it's become so much more
robust than if we created a platform
only for a certain kind of products
whether it's luxury or Street or
something and now we can actually start
to broaden it up and embrace all other
kinds of weirdnesses similarly in our
company when I look around and we look
at different people we have PhDs we have
folks from Ivy League's and we have
college dropouts and they're all in
senior positions in different kinds of
senior positions because we want to and
embrace it all then and you're working
hard I mean I wouldn't say that we are
all completely diverse we have to work
more on that diversity within the
company but the key and the mindset is
open so that and through that you can
create a lot more robustness so by
embracing your weirdness I would really
urge you to embrace the weirdness of all
of the others and through that I think
you can create something much much more
robust thank you
you